TONIGHT.
>> Sean: YES, TUCKER.
WE ARE LIVE FROM NEW YORK AS
USUAL.
GREAT SOUL.
BUCKLE OUT, WELCOME TO BE 19
BECAUSE WE ARE LESS THAN 12
HOURS AWAY, ROBERT MUELLER'S
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IS COMING.
WE WILL GET SOME QUESTIONS
ANSWERED THE WITCH HUNT.
THE BREATHLESS REPORTING HAS
BECOME THE LOOK WHO'S RUNNING
THE SHOW.
THE COWARDLY, ADAM SCHIFF,
JERRY NADLER, TWO OF THE BIGGEST
LIARS IN CONGRESS HYPING
TOMORROW'S HEARING IS A MAJOR
TURNING POINT IN THEIR
FRAUDULENT TWO AND A HALF YEAR
WITCH HUNT AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT, FOR SEPARATE
CONCLUSIONS, FOR SEPARATE
INVESTIGATIONS.
THEY HAVE LIED AGAIN AND AGAIN
PRAY THEY HAVE PRESENTED WHAT IS
NOTHING SHORT OF A HOAX.
MULTIPLE CONSPIRACY THEORIES,
MADE FALSE PROMISES, ALWAYS
CLAIMING THE PRESIDENT IS GUILTY
OF SOMETHING.
THEY CAN'T SAY, BUT SOMETHING.
THICK CONSPIRACY, COLLUSION,
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA OF YOUR
DEFRAUDING OUR ELECTIONS,
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE, SOME OF
THEIR FANDOM CRIMES.
THEIR HOPES AND PRAYERS HAVE
ALWAYS COME UP EMPTY.
I EXPECT THE SAME TOMORROW
SHOULD BE MUCH DIFFERENT BUT LET
ME BE HONEST, APPARENTLY MUELLER
IS GOING TO STICK TO THE REPORT
AS IT SAYS AND THAT'S WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE ASKING THAT.
THE REPORT WAS CLEAR.
REMEMBER ACCORDING TO MUELLER,
LEGAL PRECEDENT ON WHETHER OR
NOT A SITTING PRESIDENT CAN OR
CANNOT BE CHARGED BECAUSE OF THE
DEAL DOJ APOLOGY GOG BUT
TOMORROW, THE DEMOCRATIC
PLAYBOOK IS CLEAR.
IT'S OBVIOUS IT'S TRANSPARENT.
THEY WANT ROBERT MUELLER TO
CONTRADICT HIS OWN FINDINGS AND
IMPLICATE AND SMEAR THE
PRESIDENT.
GIVING THEM THAT ONE SOUND BITE
THAT THEY AND THEIR FRIENDS IN
THE MEDIA MOB WILL PLAY OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
SO THEY CAN HAVE ANOTHER 30
INVESTIGATIONS FOR THE NEXT TWO
YEARS.
MEANWHILE, REPUBLICANS, MY
MESSAGES TO YOU TONIGHT.
I'M NOT A REGISTERED REPUBLICAN
PEERED I'M A REGISTERED
CONSERVATIVE BUT YOU REPUBLICANS
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TOMORROW,
AND FRANKLY A GOLDEN
OPPORTUNITY, TO PERFORM ACTUAL
OVERSIGHT.
A BROADER AUDIENCE THAN YOU
WOULD USUALLY HAVE, EVEN FAKE
NEWS CNN AN END MST AND C, THE
CONSPIRACY CHANNEL, THEIR VIEW
IS WATCHING TO AND WHAT YOU DO
TOMORROW COUNTS.
YOU ARE THE ONES THAT MUST
DEMAND ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
ROBERT MUELLER.
THERE ARE SO MANY IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE NEVER BEEN
ASKED OR ADDRESSED AND TOMORROW,
THAT IS YOUR JOB.
WHAT HAPPENS TOMORROW WILL
IMPACT ON A DEEP LEVEL WHAT IS
THE BEST CONSTITUTIONAL GOD HAS
GIVEN.
EQUAL JUSTICE ON THE LAW, EQUAL
APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS, THIS
WILL IMPACT GENERATIONS TO COME
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT SOME WEAK
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS TO BLOW
IT HERE WE'VE BEEN FOLLOWING THE
STORY AND I JUST WANT TO TRY TO
LAY OUT A BASIC FUNDAMENTAL
TUTORIAL FOR THESE WEAK
REPUBLICANS THAT HAVE NO CLUE TO
FOLLOW.
LET ME BE CLEAR ABOUT.
THIS IS NOT ME TELLING PEOPLE
WHAT TO DO.
CONSERVATIVE LAWMAKERS ON THE
INTEL AND JUDICIARY COMMITTEES,
THEY DON'T NEED MY ADVICE.
DEVIN NUNES KNOWS MORE THAN I
DO.
SO DOES JOHN RATCLIFFE.
SO DOES JIM JORDAN.
SO DOES MATT GAETZ.
SO DOES LILY GO MORRIS AND MANY
WELL-INFORMED OTHERS.
BUT SADLY, THERE ARE A WELL,
MORE THAN A FEW REPUBLICANS.
YOU NEED TO PAY ATTENTION AND
YOU NEED TO DO YOUR JOB TOMORROW
AND YOU BETTER STUDY OF AND IF
YOU NEED SOMEHOW, PAY CLOSE
ATTENTION BUT AT SOME OF YOU
PROBABLY ARE NOT WELL INFORMED
ON THIS TOPIC, WHICH FRANKLY IS
PATHETIC AND IF YOU ARE A
REPUBLICAN THAT FITS INTO THAT
CATEGORY, PAY ATTENTION.
IF YOU HAVEN'T READ THE MUELLER
REPORT, THAT MAKES YOU EVEN MORE
PATHETIC I THINK THERE ARE SOME
OF YOU OUT THERE.
TOMORROW NIGHT, MY GOAL --
I DON'T WANT TO COME ON THE AIR
HERE AT THIS TIME TOMORROW AND
TELL YOU, THE VIEWERS, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THAT THEY BLEW
IT.
THAT THEY HAD A GOLDEN
OPPORTUNITY.
SO, TO LITERALLY PREVENT THAT
FROM HAPPENING, I'M GOING TO TRY
AND ASSIST FOR THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC SAY, BECAUSE WISE,
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, AND A HOAX
HAVE LED MOST OF THE MEDIA
COVERAGE BUT HERE IS MY HUMBLE
ADVICE.
ALWAYS START WITH THE BASICS.
A HANNITY RULE NUMBER ONE, NO
QUESTION SHOULD BE LONGER THAN
TEN OR 11 SECONDS.
MOVE FAST.
ASKS DISTINCT, DIRECT QUESTIONS.
YES OR NO QUESTIONS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET IN AS MANY
QUESTIONS AS TIME PERMITS.
MOVE QUICKLY.
IF MUELLER REFUSES TO ANSWER,
MOVE ONTO THE NEXT QUESTION.
IT REMINDED MR. MUELLER THAT YOU
WANT ANSWERS TO THESE QUESTIONS.
MY SECOND PIECE OF ADVICE,
STARTED AT THE BEGINNING PEERED
HILLARY CLINTON.
LISTEN CLOSELY.
HERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS.
AGAIN, I'M ONLY TOUCHING THE
SURFACE.
MR. MUELLER, THESPIAN ACT, YOUR
CAREER IN LAW'S ENFORCEMENT, IF
YOU HAVE CLASSIFIED TOP SECRET
INFORMATION ON A PRIVATE SERVER,
DOES NOT VIOLATE THE ESPIONAGE
ACT?
YES OR NO, SIR.
REMIND HIM THIS IS IMPORTANT AND
WE WILL HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER
THE LAW.
IF HE SAYS I DIDN'T LOOK INTO
THAT, I DON'T KNOW, MOVE ONTO
THE NEXT QUESTION.
IF ANYONE IN AMERICA,
MR. MUELLER, HAD A EMAIL
SUBPOENAED AND THEY DECIDED TO
ERASE AND BUST UP DEVICES WITH
HAMMERS AND DESTROY THE HARD
DRIVE, WOULD THAT BE A SLAM-DUNK
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE CASE
MR. MUELLER?
IF HE ANSWERS YES OR NO, IT
DOESN'T MATTER CAN'T.
KEEP GOING.
IF HE DOESN'T MOVE ONTO THE NEXT
SET OF QUESTIONS, YOU MOVE ON
QUICKLY.
MR. MUELLER, WENT TO THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN BEGAN AND WHY?
MR. MUELLER, WHAT ABOUT YOUR
ORIGINAL MANDATE?
'S DATA MINING, MANDATE
ROD WHEELER ROSENSTEIN POSSIBLE
CORONATION BETWEEN THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT, MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, AND ANY OTHER MATTERS
THAT ROSE DIRECTLY FROM THAT
INVESTIGATION.
MR.MUELLER, IN YOUR VIEW, DID
YOU OR A MANDATE ALLOW YOU
VIOLATIONS?
TAXING MEDALLIONS, YES OR NO?
LOAN APPLICATIONS, YES OR NO?
TAX FRAUD, YES OR NO,
MR. MUELLER?
MR.MUELLER, WHEN DID YOU FIRST
HEAR ABOUT THE PHONY CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR IT WHY
SHOULDN'T RUSSIAN DOSSIER?
WHEN DID YOU FIRST HEAR ABOUT I
IT?
AROUND ONE?
TELL US WHEN PEERED WHEN DID YOU
LEARN THAT RUSSIAN DOSSIER
BECAME THE BULK OF INFORMATION
USED AND FORTIFIES APPLICATIONS
TO SPY ON A CITIZEN AND THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
WHEN DID YOU LEARN?
AROUND WHEN DID YOU LEARN?
MR. MUELLER, AS A CAREER
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER, DOESN'T
THE INFORMATION AND ADVISE A
WARRANT NEED TO BE VERIFIED AS
TRUE BEFORE PRESENTING IT TO A
JUDGE?
MR. NINE, THE HILL RECENTLY
REPORTED THE FBI HAD A
SPREADSHEET ON DEALING THE
DOSSIER'S CLAIMS.
THEY FOUND OVER 90% OF THE
DOSSIER WAS FULL OF LIES.
MR. MUELLER, STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL KATHLEEN TO HAVE LIKE
WAR AND THE FBI AND DOJ ABOUT
THE DOSSIERS BOGUS CLAIMS, THEY
USED IT ANYWAY.
WHAT YOU SAY?
MR. MUELLER, THE DOJ OFFICIAL,
BRUCE OHR, HE RAISED AUGUST IN
2016 QUESTION ABOUT STEELE'S
CREDIBILITY.
HILLARY PAID FOR THE DOSSIER AND
THAT IT WAS NEVER ABOUT VERIFY
BUT THEY USED IT ANYWAY IN THE
FISA WARRANTS.
DID THE FBI HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO IMMEDIATELY, WHEN THEY FIND
OUT, THAT IT'S NOT TRUE THAT
THEY PUT IT IN THOSE
APPLICATIONS, DO THEY NEED TO GO
BACK TO THE PHIS ACCORDS WITH
THAT INFORMATION?
YES OR NO?
IF RUSSIA COLLUSION WAS YOUR
MANDATE, HOW IS IT POSSIBLE YOU
DIDN'T INVESTIGATE CAMPAIGN MOP
RESEARCH BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY
HILLARY CLINTON, FILLED WITH
RUSSIAN LINES?
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE
MR. MUELLER?
WHY NOT AT LEAST REFER TO
ANOTHER OFFICE FOR FURTHER
INVESTIGATION LIKE YOU DID WITH
COHEN AND TAXI IT MAKE IT
DALLIANCE?
AT ANY POINT DID YOU THINK TO
INVESTIGATE IF THERE WAS A
PREMEDITATED FRAUD COMMITTED ON
THE FISA COURT TO SPY ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN?
MR. MUELLER, AND YOUR FINAL
REPORT, THE DOSSIER WAS HARDLY
EVEN MENTIONED.
THAT IS A LYING, BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
PAID FOR BY HILLARY CLINTON.
WHY DID YOU NOT INVESTIGATE
THAT?
YOU HAD TIME TO INVESTIGATE LONE
APPLICATIONS, TAXI MEDALLIONS,
TAXES, WHY DIDN'T YOU THINK THAT
WAS IMPORTANT WHEN THAT GOES TO
THE HEART OF YOUR MANDATE?
DID YOU KNOW THAT THE FBI PAID
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, DID YOU KNOW
AND I'LL GET OLIGARCHIC PAID
HILLARY PAID CHRISTOPHER STEELE,
DID YOU KNOW THE FBI PAID
CHRISTOPHER STEELE?
HAVE YOU EVER SPOKEN TO
IF SO, HOW MANY TIMES?
WHAT'D HE SAY ABOUT HIS DOSSIER?
FULL OF RUSSIAN LIES DESIGNED TO
HER CHILD AND HER HILLARY IN THE
ELECTION?
BY THE WAY, DID BRUCE OR ACT AS
A CONDUIT AFTER STEEL WAS
ACCUSED OF LYING AND LEAKING?
WERE YOU AWARE THAT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE WAS TRYING TO
GET ANSWERS AND SEND YOU
INFORMATION WHILE YOU WERE
SPECIAL COUNSEL?
AND DID YOU KNOW THAT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, IN AN
ROGATORY THREAT OF PERJURY, I
HAVE NO IDEA IF ANY OF THIS
DOSSIER IS TRUE, DID YOU KNOW HE
SAID THAT?
WHEN DID HE SAY THAT?
IS THAT NOT SHOCK YOUR
CONSCIENCE?
NOW, YOU CHOSE NOT TO MAKE ANY
ISSUE OF THIS IN YOUR REPORT.
WHY, MR. MUELLER?
IF YOU HAD SUCH A BROAD MANDATE
TO INVESTIGATE AN ELECTION IN
INTERFERENCE, WHY DIDN'T YOU
LOOK INTO EVIDENCE THAT CLINTON
NOT UKRAINE'S HEALTH AND THE DNC
WAS WORKING TO GET UKRAINE'S
HELP TO GET DIRT ON TRUMP TO
HELP HILLARY IN THE 2016
ELECTION RUSSIAN MARK WHY DIDN'T
YOU INVESTIGATE THAT?
DOES IT MATTER IF HE INFLUENCES
COMING FROM RUSSIA OR UKRAINE?
DOES NOT MATTER?
NEXT, IT'S IMPORTANT YOU HAVE TO
COVER MUELLER'S STAFFING
DECISION.
IT MR. MUELLER, CIVIL QUESTION,
IS IT TRUE YOU CHOSE
ANDREW WEISSMANN PERSONALLY AND
THAT "THE NEW YORK TIMES" CALLED
HIM YOUR PIT BULL?
DID YOU EVER READ LICENSED ALIVE
BY SIDNEY POWELL THAT TALKS
ABOUT WISEMAN'S GOD AWFUL
HORRIFIC TRACK OF WITHHOLDING
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE?
WERE YOU AWARE OF THAT?
WHEN WERE YOU AWARE OF THAT?
WERE YOU AWARE THAT WISEMAN WAS
A DEVOUT DEMOCRAT AND THAT HE
WAS AT HER CLINTON'S VICTORY
PARTY?
WHO DID THE VETTING AND HIRING
OF THE REST OF YOUR STAFF?
WHEN DID YOU BECOME AWARE THAT
YOUR TEAM WAS ONLY MADE UP OF
BIG-TIME DEMOCRATIC OWNERS AND
ZERO REPUBLICANS?
WERE YOU AWARE THAT JEANNIE RAY
WHO WORKS FOR YOU, WORKED ON THE
HILLARY CLINTON FOUNDATION AS
HER LAWYER?
WHY WAS SHE ON YOUR TEAM?
DO NOT SEE A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST?
WHY DID YOU FIRE, OR DID YOU
FIRE STRUCK AND PAGE BECAUSE WE
KNOW ANDREW MCCABE SAYS HE
DIDN'T.
IT'S BEEN REPORTED YOU DIDN'T
SAVE STRUCK AND PAGES OF
CELL PHONES AFTER YOU BECAME
AWARE THAT THEY HAD A NANCY
TRUMP BY US.
WHY?
WHY DID YOU SEND THOSE PHONES
BACK TO ITS FACTORY THAT THEY
ARE MADE INTO GET CLEANED?
ISN'T THAT BASIC LAW ENFORCEMENT
101, SAVE THE RECORDS?
DO YOU REGRET ALL HIRING ONLY
DEMOCRATS?
AT THE VERY LEAST, DO YOU
REALIZE THE APPEARANCE OF
POLITICAL VIOLENCE AND
IMPROPRIETY IN YOUR
INVESTIGATION?
MR. MUELLER, ONE POINT IN YOUR
INVESTIGATION DID YOU REALIZE
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION OF
CONSPIRACY?
WHY DID THE INVESTIGATION
CONTINUE AFTER YOU LEARNED THE
FUNDAMENTAL TRUTH OF WHAT YOU
ARE INVESTIGATING?
NOW, BY THE WAY, AN ISSUE OF
OBSTRUCTION, THAT MUST BE TAKEN
HEAD-ON.
MR. MUELLER, WERE YOU HAVING A
TOUGH TIME ON THE ISSUE OF
OBSTRUCTION OR DID YOU TELL, NOT
TELL THE AG, ROD ROSENSTEIN, AND
OTHERS, DOJ POLICY
CONSTITUTIONAL CONSIDERATIONS
WERE NOT PART OF YOUR THINKING
WHEN IT CAME TO A DECISION NOT
TO CHARGE THE PRESIDENT WITH A
CRIME?
TO THE PRESIDENT EXERTS ANY
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE DURING YOUR
INVESTIGATION WAS AMONG THE
ANSWER IS NO.
DID HE ALLOW YOUR INVESTIGATION
OF FULL ACCESS TO THE
WHITE HOUSE, IN TERMS OF THEIR
CAMPAIGN STAFF, EVEN THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL, WHICH I
THINK IS INSANE, DID THE
PRESIDENT HAVE THE AUTHORITY
UNDER ARTICLE TWO TO FIRE AND
FBI DIRECTOR?
OR, EVEN YOU?
DID HE NOT HAVE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY TO FIRE
YOU, MR. MUELLER, IF HE DECIDED
TO DO SO?
TELL US ABOUT THE INTERVIEW WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP THE DAY BEFORE
YOU WERE HIRED AS SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
IS THAT TRUE?
IN THAT MEETING, YOU SPOKE TO
THE PRESIDENT.
DID HE TELL YOU YOU WEREN'T
GETTING THE JOB?
DID HE GIVE YOU A REASON WHY HE
FIRE JAMES COMEY?
YES OR NO, MR. MUELLER?
WHY DID YOU NOT REPEAT YOURSELF
UNDER THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES WHILE
CONSIDERING YOU WERE DENIED A
JOB I TRUMP THE DAY BEFORE?
IS IT FAIR TO SAY, MR. MUELLER,
THAT YOUR PRESIDENT, JIM COMEY,
WHAT WERE YOU ANGRY AT HIS
FIRING?
WE KNOW THE COMPANY LAKE'S
GOVERNMENT MATERIALS TO GET YOU
APPOINTED.
IS THAT A POTENTIAL VIOLATION OF
LAW?
COULD THAT BE A VIOLATION OF THE
ESPIONAGE ACT, SIR?
ARE YOU PROUD OF THE WAY YOU AND
YOUR TEAM TREATED GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS AND YOU HAD FOREIGN
SPIES LOOKING INTO HIM AND THAT
EXCULPATORY THINGS THAT HE SAID
WERE APPARENTLY WITHHELD?
ARE YOU AWARE OF THAT?
WHAT ABOUT YOUR TREATMENT OF
YOUR TEAM'S TREATMENT OF
LIEUTENANT GENERAL MICHAEL
FLYNN?
WELL, GENERAL FLYNN SERVE THIS
COUNTRY.
HE WAS A COMBAT VETERAN.
33 YEARS.
APPARENTLY HE HAS BEEN
COOPERATING WITH YOUR OFFICE FOR
A PERIOD OF TIME.
AS A CRUTCH, SIR?
HE PLED GUILTY TO LYING BUT THE
FBI AGENT INTERVIEWING HIM, HE
DIDN'T THINK THEY LIED.
RIGHT?
BUT HE MADE A PLEA AGREEMENT
ANYWAY.
ISN'T IT TRUE THAT HE LIKELY
MADE THAT PLEA AGREEMENT BECAUSE
HE WAS GOING BANKRUPT?
HE HAD TO SELL HIS HOUSE?
HE COULD NO LONGER AFFORD LEGAL
COUNSEL?
IS IT TRUE THAT THE REPORTS THAT
THIS 33-YEAR-OLD VETERAN AND HIS
FAMILY AND HIS SON THAT WAS IN
BUSINESS WITH HIM WAS THREATENED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT, ARE YOU
AWARE OF THAT?
ARE YOU AWARE THAT YOUR TEAM
DIDN'T TAKE THE PLEA TO LIED TO
THE FBI THAT HE HAD TO EVEN
THOUGH THE FBI AGENT AND HIS
INTERVIEW DIDN'T THINK HE LIKE?
DO YOU THINK HE DID IT MAY BE TO
SAVE HIS FAMILY?
DO YOU FIND THAT TYPE OF
PROSECUTORIAL TACTICS THEY ARE,
SIR?
I'M SURE YOU'RE PROUD OF THE
FACT THAT WE TREATED 33 YEAR
VETERAN THIS WAY.
WE KNOW YOUR FRIEND JAMES COMEY
ACTED THIS WAY.
ON DAY FOUR, WHEN HE SENT HIS
AGENTS INTO INTERVIEW FLYNN,
SOMETHING HE SAID HE WOULDN'T DO
TO OBAMA'S TEAM OR BUSHES TEAM,
DOES THAT BOTHER YOU ABOUT YOUR
FRIEND?
YES OR NO, MR. MUELLER?
NOW, CALL ME DID THIS AFTER HIS
DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR McKAY,
WELL, HE TOLD FLYNN HE DOESN'T
NEED A LAWYER WHEN THOSE LAWYERS
WERE GOING IN.
DO YOU BELIEVE IN MIRANDA
RIGHTS?
DO YOU THINK IT'S A RIGHT WAY TO
TREAT A 30-YEAR VETERAN OF THIS
COUNTRY, SIR QUESTION MIKE WOULD
YOU TREAT A VETERAN LIKE THAT?
LET'S LOOK AT SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS POSED BY OUR OWN
GREGG JARRETT.
THEY DRILL DOWN EVEN DEEPER ON
THE STATE.
MR. MUELLER, DID YOU INVESTIGATE
CHRISTOPHER STEELE?
USING GPS?
WHEN SOMETHING, HOW THEY
SUPPLIED RUSSIAN INFORMATION TO
THE MEDIA, THE FBI, AND THE GOG
JAY TO INFLUENCE THE ELECTION
QUESTION WANTED YOU INVESTIGATE
WHETHER JOHN BRENNAN AND
JAMES CLAPPER SPREAD DID RUSSIAN
INFORMATION ABOUT TRUMP TO
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS LIKE
MICHAEL ISIKOFF, DAVE RECORD IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST"?
ISN'T IT TRUE THAT YOUR
INVESTIGATIVE TEAM INTERVIEWED
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AT LEAST
ONCE, LIKELY CHOICE AND THREE
TIMES, WHAT DID HE TOSSED YOU?
DID YOU INTERVIEW CONFIDENTIAL
AND PERFORMANCE HELPER?
WHAT DID HE TELL YOU?
WASN'T IT TRUE THAT HE PROVIDED
THE FBI WITHIN SCOPE OF TORY
INFORMATION I CARTER PAGE,
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS DID NOT
CONSPIRE WITH THE RUSSIANS?
WHY WAS I NOT ADHERED TO?
IS IT TRUE THAT BRUCE OR A
SHARED DOSSIER INFORMATION WITH
YOUR PITIFUL, ANDREW WEISSMANN
AND MR. O MARTIN EARLY OF AUGUST
AND MR. O MARTIN EARLY OF AUGUS2
AND MR. O MARTIN EARLY OF AUGUS1
AND MR. O MARTIN EARLY OF AUGUS?
SHOULDN'T THEY HAVE REFUSED
THEMSELVES SINCE THEY WERE EARLY
WITNESSES TO THE DOSSIERS
CONTENTS AND THEY WERE TOLD IT
WAS NOT VERIFIED?
WHY DID YOU SELECT ERRANDS ALL
THE WHO REPRESENTED OH, JUSTIN
COOPER, YOU KNOW, THE GUY WHO
HELPED SET UP AND ADMINISTER
CLINTON EMAIL SYSTEM, DIDN'T HE
SMASH CLINTON'S BLACKBERRY
DEVICES OR ISN'T HE ACCUSED OF
THAT?
NOW, THE FINAL PHIS APPLICATION
AND THE THIRD WERE NEWER TO
SURVEILLED CARTER PAGE AND ALSO
SPY ON THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP,
WELL, THAT WAS DONE IN JUNE OF
2017.
YOU WERE THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
MR. MUELLER, WERE YOU EITHER
AWARE OF THIS RENEWAL?
WERE YOU INVOLVED IN THIS
RENEWAL?
WAS ANY OF THE INFORMATION
PRESENTED TO THE FISA COURT
VERIFIED?
WAS THE CLINTON DIRTY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER STILL THE BULK OF
INFORMATION IN THAT PHIS
APPLICATION?
WERE YOU AWARE THAT MUCH OF THE
APPLICATION WAS BASED ON STEALS
UNVERIFIED DOSSIER AND WHEN WERE
YOU AWARE OF IT?
DID YOU EVER DISCUSS WITH
ROD ROSENSTEIN THE PROSPECTS OF
HIS REFUSAL FROM THE CASE?
WASN'T NOT A WITNESS IN THE SAME
CASE THAT HE WAS SUPERVISING?
WHY DIDN'T YOU DEMAND HIS
REFUSAL?
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL TEAM EVER
INTERVIEW ROSENSTEIN IS A
WITNESS?
WHAT DID HE TELL YOU ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S REASONS FOR FIRING
CALL ME OR HIS SUGGESTIONS THAT
THE PRESIDENT FIRED COMING?
WHEN YOU MET WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON MAY 16, 2017,
WHY DIDN'T YOU TELL HIM YOU WERE
CONSIDERING, THE NEXT DAY, TURNS
OUT, TAKING THE POSITION OF
SPECIAL COUNSEL TO INVESTIGATE
HIM?
WHY DID YOU ARE A PART AT EDIT
AND MISREPRESENT A TELEPHONE
MESSAGE LEFT BY TRUMP ATTORNEY
DEL WITH MICHAEL FRIENDS LAWYER,
ROBERT HOMER?
ISN'T IT TRUE THAT THE OLD
OFFICE OF LEGAL COUNSEL OPINION
DID NOT PREVENT YOU FROM
RENDERING A CONCLUSION ON
WHETHER THE EVIDENCE DID OR DID
NOT SUPPORT OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE?
AS YOU CAN SEE, WE COULD GO ON
AND ON AND ON.
KEEP IT TIGHT, KEEP IT SHORT.
IT DOESN'T ANSWER, MOVE ON.
IF HE STARTS RAMBLING,
MR. MUELLER, I ONLY HAVE
5 MINUTES.
I DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME.
YES OR NO, SIR.
ASK AS MANY SHORT QUESTIONS AS
POSSIBLE.
YOUR MISSION SHOULD BE TO INFORM
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT A
DIRTY DOSSIER.
USE TO LITERALLY SPY ON THE
OPPOSITION PARTY AND CANDIDATE
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIVES THAT
ROBERT MUELLER IGNORED.
LET THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THE
TRUTH.
ALSO, BREAKING NEWS ON THE EVE
OF THIS MUELLER TESTIMONY.
HE ACTUALLY MADE A LAST-MINUTE
REQUEST THAT ONE OF HIS TOP
DEPUTIES, ERRANDS UGLY,
ACCOMPANY HIM DURING THE
HEARING.
WOW.
THIS IS PRETTY INTERESTING
BECAUSE THIS GUY SERVED AS
MUELLER'S CHIEF OF STAFF OF THE
FBI.
HE ALSO PREVIOUSLY REPRESENTED
JUSTIN COOPER.
THAT'S A FORMER JUSTIN COOPER
ADVISOR IN THE HILLARY SCANDAL.
HE HELPED SET UP THE
SECRET SERVICE.
HE CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
MOMENTS AGO, THE PRESIDENT
TWEETED JUST OUTBACK ONLY TO
HEAR A LAST-MINUTE CHANGE
ALLOWING A NEVER TRUMPER
ATTORNEY TO HELP OUT
ROBERT MUELLER WITH HIS
TESTIMONY BEFORE CONGRESS TO
MARKET WHAT A DISGRACE TO OUR
SYSTEM.
I'VE NEVER HEARD OF THIS BEFORE.
VERY UNFAIR.
SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED.
NOW WE HAVE A RIGGED WITCH HUNT
AND A GREAT TESTIMONY.
IT IN CASE MULLER'S PRACTICE
SESSIONS WERE NOT GOING WELL
BECAUSE APPARENTLY HE HAS BEEN
PRACTICING ALL WEEK, SO HAS
NADLER.
MULLER'S REQUEST THAT ONE OF HIS
TOP DEPUTIES PRESIDENT AT
SWANSEA AND, NOT THE ONLY
DEVELOPMENT.
YESTERDAY, LETTER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE INSTRUCTED
THE NINE THAT HIS TESTIMONY MUST
REMAIN WITHIN THE BOUNDARIES OF
THE PUBLIC REPORT.
INDUCTIVELY, THE MEDIA WENT NUTS
SAYING SHE PART IS I WANT THE
TRUTH ACCUSING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF TRYING TO
SILENCE ROBERT MUELLER ON TRYING
TO INTIMIDATE HIM AHEAD OF THE
TESTIMONY.
WE ARE ONLY AN ENTIRE NEW CYCLE,
TOTALLY THEIR FAKE PHONY OUTRAGE
AS USUAL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THEY ARE STILL SCARED HE MAY
GO BROKE.
THERE IS STILL A LITTLE BIT
SCARED ABOUT 1% POSSIBILITY.
EVERYTHING WE KNOW ABOUT BOB
MUELLER, --
STICK I THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY
ARROGANT TO TRY TO INSTRUCT HIM
WHAT TO SAY IS PART OF THE
ONGOING COVER-UP BY THE
ADMINISTRATION TO KEEP
INFORMATION AWAY FROM THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> YOU DON'T NEED TO TELL HIM TO
STICK TO THE FOUR CORNERS OF HIS
REPORT.
IT'S LIKE TELLING A PLAN NOT TO
MOVE HERE AND HE DIDN'T NEED THE
FLATTERY.
>> OKAY, REALLY?
WILL THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.